depuis le 1er juin antoine est installé
dans ce logement refait à neuf à
versailles son premier logement ces
relogements couple c'est assez spacieux
pour ce 26 mètres carrés il paie 554
euros auxquels il faut encore déduire
les apl à loyer dérisoire comparé au
prix du marché
car antoine et son amie jessica ont pu
intégrer un foyer jeunes travailleurs la
résidence marcel callo géré par les
apprentis d'auteuil elle a pu être
rénové après une fermeture de trois ans
à l'aide du diocèse de versailles
d'emmaüs habitat et des subventions des
collectivités territoriales pour les
investissements à mettre il fallait
trouver 5 millions donc
nous ne les avons pas on a nous
contribue beaucoup en donnant les locaux
pour 45 ans à emmaüs habitat et à charge
pour lui de restaurer l'ensemble plus
qu'un logement la fondation apprentis
d'auteuil met à leur disposition trois
intervenants sociaux pour aider les
jeunes dans leur projet professionnel ou
leurs démarches administratives
le défi consolante l'ambition de ce
projet là avec mon espace politique
c'est une puce le soir prend du temps
pour se rencontrer échanger entre eux et
pouvoir gagner en confiance
julien fait partie des 98 résidents de
18 à 25 ans du foyer jeunes travailleurs
originaires du sud de la france il a
souhaité monter à paris pour concrétiser
son projet musical
après être passé de canapé en canapé de
sous location sous location il a pu
s'installer dans la résidence
c'est vrai qu'il ya une émulation en
fait au final parce qu'on se retrouve
tous à vouloir avancer dans la vie et
voilà on a on a ses chances qui me sont
donnés par le foyer se sont entrés
l'important fonds grâce à la stabilité
du foyer julien a pu développer son
label de musique
il sortira son premier projet au moins
de février prochain